rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message keep things in perspective
over to you Dave Chappelle when I was
maybe 19 I opened for a wreath of
Franklin at Radio City Wow nice yeah
looking back on it I'm sure she didn't
choose me herself
but it was great it was it was great I
was want to go back as the headliner oh
my god but 19 and like when I was 19 I
had a paper rod but did we're looking
back on it were you prepared at 19 for
that kind of a gig yeah it was 15
minutes I had about 30 minutes then
mm-hmm
you know I was prepared enough yeah I
mean was that as good as a wreath of
Franklin no no well my job is just to
get people used to looking at the stage
I'm hoping that yeah it mattered to me
if I did good but nobody really cared is
this you know a big gig like this they
they have a rehearsal do they have a
walkthrough they have like a sound
checks and that kind of thing I don't
know I imagine he'll be a sound check
you know he could either go with send a
guy right wouldn't you were 19 did you
go for a sound check well I skipped it
which was a terrible mistake that was a
mistake it was a terrible mistake I
skipped the sound check and nobody could
hear me for the first three minutes but
you know you know what it is they you've
been a stand-up for many years and and
you know you probably get that question
when people tell my god you're a
comedian well what happens if you go out
there and you tell your jokes and no one
laughs nothing happens you get paid the
same you're not gonna die and a bad
happen so I keep it all in perspective
so I think it's super important for
entrepreneurs to be able to keep things
in perspective because I think a lot of
times at the beginning when you're
starting a business you have unrealistic
expectations of what you can do
especially in the short run I see so
many entrepreneurs who realize that
getting their business started just way
more difficult than they expected I see
so many people try to get started on
YouTube as an example and they make one
video and they make three videos and I
make five videos or ten videos and they
don't get results they don't get any
views you don't get any comment and
suddenly their life sucks and they need
to quit that and go off to something
else this is not gonna work for me I
have to go do something else when was
the last time you tried something five
times and
just instantly worked did you pick up a
basketball and try five times and then
suddenly you're Michael Jordan that's
not how skills work you may know what
looks good and this is a challenge you
know what looks good you know what a
good video looks like you know what a
good jump shot looks like you know what
a good shoe or a good book or a good
coffee cup you know what it looks like
but that doesn't mean you can instantly
create it yourself at the beginning
you're gonna suck at everything
just like you always have for everything
you've done just like everybody else for
me it's taking six thousand videos to
get to this point maybe you can learn it
a lot faster than I did but you're not
chances are gonna learn it in five or
ten it's gonna take a lot of effort the
quantity leads to the quality and so
just keeping that in perspective that
whatever you start off doing you're not
gonna be very good at you're not gonna
have a lot of results that it's gonna
take a ton of work for very minimal
results and then slowly as you get
better as you keep hustling as you keep
grind as you keep working on it so my
passion is so important because you have
to deal with a lot of crap and a lot of
tiny results at the beginning to get
actually good at something so that you
can actually now increase the results
ultimately your business success will
come from be able to provide value to
somebody else but at the beginning you
can't provide a lot of value because you
don't know what you're doing yet and
that's okay you learn you get better you
start off doing something for free and
then you start charging a little bit and
then as you get better and better and
better you become hopefully the best in
the world at what you do you start to
charge more you start to build a team
you start to have a bigger impact
because you're bringing so much more
value and so just keep it on in
perspective at the beginning that you're
gonna suck it whatever you do that's
okay so when you fall when you suck when
you don't create a great result that's
okay that's part of your learning
process and I try to take that to every
new thing that I'm doing having the
confidence that if I want to do it if I
want to keep getting better at it then I
can and I expect the suck at the
beginning of everything the other thing
that I like to do this might be a bit of
a mind twist and see if you guys would
be with me or not
I don't mind making mistakes and showing
them off and not fixing them just as a
reminder to myself that it's okay to
make mistakes that I'm not perfect and a
reminder to you guys hopefully in that
lesson that you don't have to be perfect
either
so as an example on my youtube channel
there was an entire month
worth of videos where we had terrible
sound normally a my sound they have a
clip mic so I've got this on on here
hopefully it's working fingers crossed
and the camera is actually way across
the room for whatever reason the mic
here wasn't working we didn't do a sound
check it wasn't working properly and we
did the entire month worth of videos a
lot of videos three videos a day off of
the microphone from the camera that's
way over there so it sounds like I'm in
this huge cave and some of these videos
are super popular some of these videos
have had millions of minutes of watch
time on it and are some of the most
popular videos on my channel and I chose
purposely not to rerecord them we found
out pretty quickly once Christina got
the video she's like you sounds like
you're in a cave we found that pretty
quickly and I could have reshot them but
I chose not to I chose to release the
imperfect nests as a reminder to myself
that sometimes that's okay that I can
make mistakes and yes I want to strive
to be better and super perfection always
is a constant battle but sometimes I
make mistakes and that's okay and I
wanted to share that with you guys and
maybe I lost some subscribers and maybe
I didn't grow as quickly as I could have
and if I lost a subscriber because the
audio quality wasn't perfect for a month
you know that happens but sometimes I
just like being able to put up imperfect
products I don't know maybe that's just
an Evan thing but it's why I kept those
videos up it's why you can watch my
entire journey if you go back on my
channel you can watch some of the first
videos I put up and how terrible I was
on camera and people asked why do you
keep putting like why do you keep those
videos up you're just so much better as
a speaker now cuz I like showing the
journey I like showing the imperfections
I like being able to tell people that I
sucked at the beginning and that even
now I'll still make mistakes and that
even now even though we have a million
subscribers I'll still make videos off
my cellphone sometimes and I'll still
make videos off my webcam and that
sometimes I have audio issues and
sometimes you know stuff happens even
now because I know that I'm not perfect
and yes it's that constant battle but
it's okay when I'm not and it's okay for
you guys not to be too much more
important than making that one perfect
video is the march forward that tomorrow
I'm trying harder to be better on the
next day I'm trying hard to be better
and that I'm seeing that growth
for myself personally as well as for the
business and for every goal that I set
it to achieve so maybe that second mine
twist is just an everything maybe it's
something other people do as well but I
thought that I would share it with you
guys so the question they today is I'm
curious what is one thing that you do to
help keep things in perspective that
maybe you get stressed out in the moment
and this one thing you do helps keep
things in perspective for you it helps
relax yourself a little bit more what is
that one thing I think by you sharing it
it could help other people from believe
nation watching this video as well who
might need a little bit extra support so
share that in the comments below I'm
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say thank you guys for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of an espresso
do you feel underrated as a rapper not
as of lately like which is crazy for a
long time and for years I was pissed so
a song on the album called buried alive
his use it's about that exactly you know
it's about like me kind of going how
come he gets this so-and-so cosine or
how come he gets that or how come they
get that I can tour the world I can sell
up shows I got fans I got this one man
like being angry you know I had a friend
tell me she basically said those same
people who have the cosines and have the
dis and have the looks are the same
people are going how come I got fans
like this dude how come I can't tell
where on my own how come I can't dislike
with them so kind of put things in
perspective for me and let me go okay I
don't have it yet but if I keep fighting
I keep working hard and I keep staying
on this path it's gonna happen you know
and as of late within the last few
months man just from you know like
releasing the singles and the music
videos and like this solid body of work
I've truly began to to get what I
deserve
I'm entrepreneur it's very great but not
all days are great in a company so what
are your tips and tricks for tough days
I think there's massive confusion around
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I mean
I can't live without it but it's like a
bad boyfriend right a girlfriend right
like like it's there's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur
not to mention 98% of entrepreneurial
ventures are gonna fail so there's gonna
be a really bad day in your future um
you know hopefully not for you um for
any of you you know for me
I don't you know I think this is a very
personal question I think it's how
you're wired I'm so all-in entrepreneur
I prefer the pain I think one of the
reasons I love the Jets so much is
because they bring me so much pain you
know I I love the climb to me the
setback is exciting I love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most but that's not for everybody
right I mean it can be very difficult
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all the other
things it can get real nasty to me the
way I handle things even though the few
rare days when I really struggle I take
a real step back
and make pretend that somebody called me
and told me that my mother or daughter
were killed and I know that's very dark
and I apologize but it's really what I
do I literally am able to at my deepest
most struggling moment within business
take a step back and remind myself that
I can make a trillion dollars tomorrow
on Bitcoin and and if something bad
happened to the people I love the most
that it would mean nothing and it very
consistently rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's it's
money for me it's not really money it's
my legacy so I get hurt by it a little
bit more but uh yeah I mean it's you
know I put it in perspective it's money
and you know what up until I had a
daughter even while I was married up
until when I had Nisha four years ago I
secretly wanted to lose all my money I
had this weird twisted dark fantasy of
losing everything just to rise again
like a phoenix and remind you when you
have a down time like if something
didn't hear the way you want what you do
to get back on that positivity I talked
to the mountain I have a mountain next
to my home that is called the Washington
a it goes up to two it's very low goes
up to two thousand four two thousand
five hundred meters oh I talked to the
dog DVD which is four thousand meters
which is really the further away from my
house which I see every morning I see
those two mountains and I say to these
two mountains mountains I have a problem
well but when I look at you you are 37
million strong a little guy here will be
little problem can you help me and they
will say come on look what we have
already see it so many years
no problem is an a no problem the most
important word ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
kind of like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details